before introduced with these leaked
scripts let me just say that the scripts
for the final season were completed as a
Wednesday July 26th while those leaks on
the other hand have been published in
August so there's a chance that these
leaks are in fact genuine anyways if you
don't want anything to be potentially
spoiled it's time for you to close this
video there stated that the season
premiere starts with aftermath of the
night Kings attack on
eastwatch-by-the-sea and that Viserion
sets Krauss and undead afire torment
engage we are able to flee the scene but
beric Dondarrion stays behind
berrak fights against the army of the
dead and supposedly dies off-screen but
not before killing the white Walker that
killed ed ed his stabbed to death by
white Walker a bit earlier Thurman that
ginjury ride for Winterfell Will's the
seer burn in Castle black in the
background then we go to Winterfell
there stated that Daenerys and John with
their teams arrived in Winterfell
that was remarks that it has gotten much
colder and darker since he has left with
Jon Jon firstly reunites at Arya the
nearest meet sends a stark and Sansa
asks whether she and Jon are now in love
the nurse does not give a proper
response
Sansa does not seem to be pleased with
Jon returning to Winterfell nor with the
nurses presence let me just stop here
for a moment to say that I'm not sure if
this part of the leaked script is
pointing out that sense is not pleased
with Jon's return which would be quite
strange since she's the one that pretty
much stated that the Starks had to stay
together in the pack now that winter has
arrived or it might be pointing out that
senses not happy with Jon bringing the
dragon queen to Winterfell
this would also be quite surprising
since senses should be smart enough to
understand that without Daenerys and her
dragons the living side would not stand
a chance against the night king and his
vast army anyways then there stated that
Jon Odie's a sense of concerns and talks
with her to settle everything down Sansa
mentions Littlefinger's death and how he
always betrayed them right under their
nose upon finding out that Jon and
others have made a pact with Cersei
Lannister
census says that it's plain stupid to
work with her the hound and Arya also
reunite and have a conversation with
each other
he tells the Hound she did not regret to
leave him behind without having him
killed off the Hound responds that she
should have had him killed off right
there before he has seen all those
things beyond the wall the scene then
switches from interval to King's Landing
young rage arrives back in the capital
with golden company they have a meeting
with Cersei Lannister in the throne room
Cersei tanks urine from bringing the
golden company with his own fleet to
King's Landing
he orders the commander-in-chief to take
the ancestral seat of house Baratheon
and to have the army gathered in the
fortress serfs explains that Robert
Baratheon once told her that the
fortress has stood for many centuries
and she is sure that it will keep
standing during the long night as well
since there's no Baratheon holding the
castle any longer it will not be too
difficult to just take it themselves
Cersei also says they will need to
protect themselves during the Great War
and storms and is basically their best
chance for survival let me just stop
here for a moment who said that this
part would make a lot of sense since
storm central is one of the mightiest
fortresses on the entire continent and
is said to be protected by spells woven
to its walls that prevent magic from
penetrating its defenses storms and has
endured many sieges but has never fallen
to an attacker in its millennial own
history and therefore Cersei deciding to
place her troops over there doesn't come
as a huge surprise after all season 7
finale revealed that sirs his main
intention in the final season will be
retrieving lands that in her opinion
belong to her anyways back to the leaked
scripts
later that night Eurasia is about to
have an intimate relations with Cersei
urine jokes that she will not miss her
bladder after she finds out what he can
give her but search his face expression
reveals her real feelings the following
morning urine leaves with his shipped
silence to ferret the golden company to
storms end to take the fortress while
traveling back to King's Landing York
has a conversation with his niece er
about Queen Cersei he are openly tells
him that she knows he is not interested
in being queen sources that husband at
all
Joran laughs and tells her that his good
friends from Brow's will take care of
that problem soon enough let me just say
that urine is either referring to their
own bank or more probably to a guild of
assassins the faceless man both based in
the free city of Braavos
in the novel's its implied that urine
hired a faceless man to kill his brother
Balin which made him the king of the
Iron Islands there's a possibility that
in the show up on Marin Queen Cersei
urine might hire faceless men to kill
Cersei which would make him the ruler of
the Seven Kingdoms
anyways upon arriving back to the
capital urine tell Cersei that it's time
for them to finally marry then we are
going back to the north same reunites
with Jon and the two share a hug John
tells Sam he's glad to have him back
Daenerys John sense a Tyrion Davos and
his Sam varies the northern Lords and
Knights of the Vale gather in the
whole of Winterfell Lord Robin and Lord
John Royce are also present in the scene
the northern Lords are not too pleased
to accept the nearest as their queen
then there's defense herself very well
but she does not get the support of the
north just yet Liana Mormon tells the
names Targaryen that she will never call
her your grace because she only knows
one king and that's Jon Snow the king in
the north
Tyrion smile some mentions that she's a
ferocious girl on which jaw replies that
the Mormons don't stand back for
anything John tells them there's no time
to argue with each other and brings up
that there has not been a word of the
Lannister army yet since a response that
she warned them not to trust Cersei
Lannister
Tyrion mentions that they can trust his
brother Jaime but the nearest does not
seem to agree on this one the group
discusses how they will defend the north
against the knight king's army John
tells Robin it's wise to bring her into
the fold and to Lord Knight King in
there Robin doesn't really seem to care
and accepts John's proposal after the
meeting the nurse tells John that the
northerners really are stubborn and
small-minded people there's then stated
that Theon Greyjoy visit the godswood of
Winterfell and thinks of his friend Rob
and meets with bran stark as we all know
the last time we've seen Theon he did
not leave with Jon and Daenerys from
Winterfell
but his Railly the remaining Ironborn
left in Dragonstone and formed a rescue
party so he could at least try to save
Yara there's a possibility that funeral
leader in the episode arrived on the
Aran Islands only to find out that
Europe has led for Essos with his arm
fleet to bring the golden company
upon figuring out that his rescue
mission failed as you're most certainly
did not leave Yara behind
Theon would possibly go to Winterfell
where the nearest and the rest currently
are but there is no mention of that in
the lake script anyways there stated
that fee and immediately apologizes to
bran for everything he has done against
how stark but Brennan tells him there's
no need for that Brett knows that
feeling has redeemed himself by saving
his sister Sansa bran all servals
fulfilling that he has seen how much he
has suffered at the hands of Ramsay
Bolton
Theon asks him how he knows all of this
but bran doesn't respond to that Orion
brainer training and Jon is impressed by
his sister's fighting skills Arya
mentions that she has never forgotten to
stick her enemies with the pointy end
which was her first lesson that she
received from Jon in the second episode
of the very first season
s-sorry Aviv she did not join the
meeting in the Great Hall of Winterfell
or the answers that senses very better
in those things than shields let me go
from Westeros vessels in meléndez lady
Melisandre enters the red temple before
I go any further let me just remind you
that earlier in the season seven
Melisandre revealed to Aries that she
decided to depart for volantis shortly
so this does not come and expect it
Melisandre is welcomed by Kimbra who is
the High Priestess of the red temple at
volantis now a Sanja tells Canberra that
she's played her part in the great war
to come
she has United Ice and Fire she has
served King Jon Snow the prince was
promised and brought him back to life
kimimaro tells Melisandre that she's
heard their God well on that part but
she also made a lot of mistakes where
she needs to pay for camara tells
Melisandre that their God demands one
more sacrifice of Melisandre which
requires her to return to Westeros to
the north
Melisandre answers that she is not
allowed to enter the North Kim are
smiles and answers Melisandre that she
could benefit from her punishment then
back to Westeros we see Jaime Lannister
a Dean at Crossroads where he reunites
with bran Jaime is surprised to see bran
and asks him why he followed him bran
answers that there's nothing left for
him in that stinking city and he is down
for some adventure in the north Jaime is
glad to have Brown by his side bran asks
Jaime why he has led the woman he loves
the most but Jamie does not completely
respond to his question then he asks
what he's planning to do now that he has
led King's Landing Jamie tells brand
that he's on his way to river and to
bring the garrisoned Lannister army back
to the fold
bran asks him why he would give up the
castle he has been occupying and Jaime
answers with what purpose and game would
River and help for me for all I care
Admiral can have it back the last scenes
take place at Winterfell
tormund and ginjury finally arrive over
there Jon Snow asks sense our I bran
didn't take the time to join the meeting
in a great hole and didn't even come to
speak to him since the tells John that
bran has changed a lot and calls himself
the three-eyed raven now she tells him
not to expect much of a conversation
with him Sam comes in between and tell
Jon there's something he and bran or
gently need to tell him bran first sees
Jon in godswood John mentions that he
has encountered the verge beyond the
wall on which same response that bran is
much more than a March he possesses a
magical ability to perceive the future
past or distant events in dreams the two
then inform Jon Snow about
his parentage which John doesn't seem to
believe on the first glance in order to
convince John that he is telling the
truth
Brent tells John that he knows
everything about him Brent says I saw
you beyond the walls surrounded by free
folk I saw you fighting at hardhome
against night King and his army and I
saw how you were stabbed to death by
your own man John still cannot really
believe he's a Targaryen the season
premiere of the final season ends with
Sam stating to John that he's the one
with the right claim on the Iron Throne
not the nearest Targaryen but Aegon
Targaryen